Hey guys.  *BORK BORK*
Guess whose birthday it is, today?
*MINE? IS IT MINE? I THINK ITS ME*
Chica is
years
old  *SHEESH I COULD BE A GRANDMOTHER*
As of today
And she is every bit of the cutie
As the day I got her. *I BETTER BE*
She is a wonderful girl
Who deserves the bestest birthday *AWE I LOVE YOU TOO MARK... SOMETIMES*
Of anyone in the whole wide world
So everyone please
In the comments below
Wish Chica
The happiest birthday ever in the history of forever
And uh...
Yeah, I'm gonna be spending some quality time with her  *YAAAAAAAAY*
Well, I'm gonna be streaming today over on Twitch *NOOOOOO*
But also, I'm gonna spend some quality time
With her *YAAAAAY*
To make her birthday
Cause you're special *Yea I am*
I gotta go find you a cake
We just got back from vacation so I haven't had time to
Uh, get her anything
But I had to scoop her up
From her little hotel last night *Luxury doggo*
But, uh...
Yeah
We'll be doing something special for you, pup *YAY*
I'm thinking something with lots of dog-friendly cake *LOTS OF YUM IN MY TUM*
Dog-friendly treats
And, uh...
Lots of toys
So, maybe since it's her 4th
Since it's her 4th birthday
Every 4,000 likes on this video
I will buy her a new dog toy
How 'bout that?
No, that's gonna get me in trouble *YEP*
Hang on
Wait no
Uhm...
That's too many
You know what? Actually...
She's worth it *Yeah I am*
Look at her. *IM BUTIFUL*
She is so
Every 4,000 likes
I will buy her another dog toy *YES PLEASE*
Which means if there's 40,000 likes
I will buy her 10 toys
If there is 400,000 likes
Which is very unlikely *NO IT'S NOT*
I will buy her 100 toys
But I'm probably gonna end up buying her
Way more toys than I ever intended.*IM FINE WITH THAT*
That's a good girl. *BORK BORK*
So anyway
I'll see you over on Twitch
And I will see you later
And I will be spending quality time with yOuUuUu *YAAAAAY*
At some point later today
Mwah! Love you
Love you guys
Oh, and Henry's here too *NO LEAVE HENRY*
HENRY. *NO ITS A ME DAY*
HENRY IT'S NOT YOUR BIRTHDAY! *YOU TELL HIM MR.MARKIMOO*
IT'S NOT YOUR BIRTHDAY! *BORK BORK IT'S MINE*